- Nothing would make me happier
than to post this clip 14 months from now
when you and J Balvin and Bieber
have got a song that
is number one on iTunes
and I'm gonna be like, "Yo! I
was a part of that process!"
(laughter)
And I know it can happen.
Here's why, you're an actual artist.
(upbeat music)
- [Gary] What's going on?
- [Hannah] Not much is going on.
I'm really enjoying working here.
- That makes me happy.
- [Hannah] I've been here for
a year and two months now.
And I really, really like it.
- And so what's been
the best part of Vayner?
- [Hannah] I think just
the people and the team.
I feel like that is kind of
somewhat of a cliche answer.
I also think the people --
- I also truly believe if people
are happy that is our truth
What can I help you with?
- [Hannah] You inspire
so many people each day
for your content and your
commenting back on your videos.
Who inspires you the most each day?
- The community as a whole is
the inspiration I think for me
I'm not easily inspired.
I don't, I think I'm,
I don't know. I feel like I'm almost like,
you know how like the
batteries have the two sides?
Like the A/B --
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- I feel like I'm the
reverse. I feel like that
already had happened or
was hardwired into me.
I've never, I don't even know,
I've never been inspired
the way I inspire others.
I've never, I think,
it's very interesting, that's not true
at non-profit events I
can get very inspired
where human beings are
doing real things for life
but not in a business-y kind of like,
not in business, not in career, you know.
- [Hannah] Yeah, the question
was more like generally.
- Generally, what I am most
inspired by is the hardest
emails that I have in my inbox,
which is "I'm a single mother of two.
"I'm working three jobs.
"I read 'Crush It' on
the night shift of this.
"Do you think I could
start a jewelry brand?"
You know, that's just like, fuck, right?
- [Hannah] Yeah
- I'm like, people are complaining about
it's hard to make more content,
and I'm like mother fucker,
this woman has got like --
sees her kids for an hour
a day cause she works
21 hours a day, not 15,
and not out of the shit
she's aspiring to do,
out of like providing.
- [Hannah] Right.
- I'm very inspired by people that
are suffocated out of options
and still have the fucking
intestinal fortitude
to bite their lip, put their head down
and fucking try to grind
for the next 17 years,
just to get a vacation one day.
That inspires me tremendously.
Cause that's hard.
- [Hannah] Yeah
- I'm inspired when it's hard.
- I'm not inspired by "Woe is
me. I can't find my passion."
You know (shrugs).
- [Hannah] Yeah.
- I'm just not --
- [Hannah] I get what you're saying.
- Awesome.
- [Hannah] Thank you for your time.
- Thank you. Have a great day.
- [Hannah] Have fun with your day.
- In terms of just the
one world in general,
is there any overarching advice or --
- No man, you know what,
yes, there is one thing.
The reason I think I did really well.
I think this company does really well,
and this will be good
with any comeback round,
is the wine world is not consumer-centric.
The wine world's about the wine world.
And that's why they all fucking lose.
And very honestly, the business world's
about the business world.
They worry about themselves,
not about the actual customer,
and that's why companies like Amazon,
or people like me, win so much.
Because when you actually
are consumer-centric,
- [Billy] Hear what you're saying.
- So the more you can help
them be consumer-centric,
care about what people
are pairing wines with,
how they're drinking them,
in what environments, in what packaging.
Not you've decided the story is
the dog did this, or the
malolactic fermentation that,
or this is how many months, got it?
Everybody decides their story
and tries to ram it down the
throat, instead of listening.
So I'll give you a big piece of advice,
go out a lot and go to
wine places and listen.
- [Billy] Do you --
- I won 'cause I sat
behind a register for years,
and watched the people
interact in a store,
and then had the ability to translate
that intuition and understanding
into how we interact with technology.
The end.
- [Bridget] Nice to meet you.
- Hi, nice to meet you.
- [Bridget] I'm Bridget.
- Bridget, it's such a pleasure.
- Kind of just wanted to pick your brain
for what 2018 is gonna look like.
I've heard you say it's gonna be amazing,
and I just wanna hear what's so exciting?
What's coming down the line?
- I think the world's coming to us.
So (audio cuts out) --
and the deal flow of companies
that want us to give strategies
and then creative executions.
People want Facebook videos.
People want Alexa skills.
People want influencer
programs on Instagram.
They don't want billboards.
They don't want programmatic banner ads.
I think our contemporary
nature of marketing
is feeling more practical
to the biggest companies in
the world, not futuristic.
We will benefit
disproportionately for that.
- [Bridget] Cool.
Awesome.
- Thanks.
- [Bridget] Thanks so much for your time.
- Have a great day.
What up, vlog?
Kim and I from Vayner Experience
are talking about Cannes next year.
What are the dates?
- [Man] June 18th through June 22nd.
- June 18th to June 22nd,
we're debating our overall strategy.
I'm gonna do a little biz
dev Sunday on Thursday.
We're thinking about putting on a series.
I'm looking for sponsorship of people
that are trying to get
into the marketing world,
if you have a SAS product,
things of that nature.
Basically deciding two
very different paths.
One is gonna require me
creating a 400,000 dollar event,
so between sponsorships and dinner series.
I'm just throwing this out there.
And this is obviously for only one percent
of the people watching,
but if you are trying
to tap into the marketing world,
or the big brand worlds, and you are
a start-up with SAS products or a service,
or things of that now.
From an international standpoint,
a lot of European watchers right now.
Feel free to send an email to here.
Cannes biz or biz Cannes,
I'll just come up with it.
Vaynercannes@vaynermedia.com, create it.
Vaynercannes, it'll be
spelled here, C-A-N-N-E-S.
At Vaynermedia.com, if you
are looking to sponsor,
and don't waste your time because
it's more valuable to you,
definitely Kim's time.
We're looking for sponsors
with 25,000 to 400,000 dollar packages.
We'll put on dinners. We'll put on events.
But I'm going to decide
in the next week or so
what our strategy is.
Fuck it. Let me jam with you
guys, so see what happens.
- Daily Vee over the holidays,
what are we doing today?
- I'd like you three to get fucking busy
and put out, make some fucking films.
- [Man] That's what I thought.
- [Kim] (laughs) Do it
again and (mumbles).
(both laugh)
- [Dennis] You are (mumbles).
- How are you, man?
It's a real pleasure.
- [Dennis] I'm tired
after 30 hours of flying.
- Yeah, that's a beast.
Please sit.
To your point, it's a smart observation.
Once you fucking ladder this
up to a global conversation,
it becomes real fucking interesting.
And you've done that with your brand,
you took it to a global level,
which then let's you play different chess,
because I'm sure if we
looked at the fucking score,
where your brand sits in Chile
versus where it sits in Singapore,
where it sits in Detroit,
they're gonna just be
fucking different matrix.
- [Woman] Whatever Stu wants to do along
with his brand, I think --
- Would he do it the way that I do it,
where I have people following me around,
and they're just chopping up the content.
Would you do that, Dennis?
- Never slightly do that.
- I mean, look, I've built
my entire thing, Dennis,
100 percent through this fucking thing.
Instagram, Snapchat, Facebook, podcasts.
Dennis is culture,
literally as long as
he's, to your point, seen.
I know that Dennis, on a
Facebook watch and a podcast,
gets seen way more than
any reality show execution
to produce unlimited amount
of content around Dennis,
that Dennis gets to approve,
for Instagram, Snapchat,
podcasts, YouTube.
That's the fucking game. The end.
Now what's different though,
of a reality show or one you do it,
is you're always catching everything.
You're not scared to be your full self,
because you're in charge
of post-production.
I'm literally myself all the time
because I'm in charge of what pumps out.
I'm like, "Iris, don't put that in there."
Done. There's no debate.
So the control of the fucking content
is the game.
- [Dennis] Yeah.
- The reason this will work
for you more than anybody
is the truth is the only
thing that fucking wins.
- [Dennis] You not build this brand
- 100 percent.
- [Dennis] I can't just be myself.
- [Chris] Oh no you did it yourself.
- 100 percent. You took attention,
and you reversed the
leverage in your favor.
Period. End of story.
I understand it cold.
When you were doing it,
now, now the key though is,
what you had back in the day, Dennis,
was you had distribution.
You had people watching.
What you need is to
control people watching,
and the same shit will happen again.
That's all.
Hogan was the biggest
thing in the fucking world
from '84 to '87, when
everybody was watching.
He wasn't in 1993, then
fucking wrestling came back,
and everybody gave a fuck
in '96 to '98, and he was.
It's just attention.
Dennis is a top hundred famous person,
whenever he has people actually watching.
(high fives) My man.
Where are you with music, like mentally?
- Mentally I'm a hundred percent.
- [Gary] Meaning you
want to produce projects?
- Absolutely.
- You just need to make,
because what's crazy
about the kind of talent you have,
and the status you have (shrugs).
You're just one bar away from
everything changing again.
That's just crazy to me, right?
What I don't know, and this is the truth,
is how fancy you are.
And what I mean by fancy is
how romantic you are about shit.
My intuition is you are romantic,
'cause you should be,
- Absolutely.
- And I wanna reframe the romance.
- Is it in the same frame as passionate?
- No. I would say passion you've got.
It's why you're gonna win.
I could see it comes through
in everything you do.
No, I mean you thinking
something isn't quality enough
for you to put your name on it,
'cause you protected it so well.
And you not realizing it's all upside,
and you're seeing it as downside.
- And that comes from my audience as well.
- 100 percent.
- My audience and we met on --
We have a goal.
- And you know --
My man, I know.
- We have a (mumbles).
- I'm ready, and honestly
here's my concern.
I think they've put you in a cage.
- They probably did.
- They sure did, my man.
- They sure did.
And you know what happens
when you get in a cage,
you don't do shit.
- Probably just stay in a box.
- But you're in a cage, and I know it.
And I'm just trying to make
you think of it as a macro,
and I know why you're not,
because of everything I've just said.
There is no 77 year old hip-hop icon yet,
but I think that's what you are.
And if you thought that too, well then,
fuck, I've got a lot of work to do.
Instead of, that's what I did.
That's a young man's game,
and I'm on to being an artist,
a philanthropist, an entrepreneur, got it?
I don't believe that.
I think you could have the
number one record in the country.
Tomorrow.
- Stepping out of the box.
- Stepping out the box
that they put you in.
That you put yourself in.
That you and your man put yourself in.
Step the fuck out,
and nothing would make me happier
than to post this clip 14 months from now,
when you and J Balvin and Bieber
have got a song that's
number one on iTunes,
and I'm gonna be like,
"Yo, I was a part of that process."
(laughter)
And I know it can happen.
Like, here's why.
You're an actual artist.
You putting out a song that gets hot.
That's a foregone conclusion.
You just need to get
the fuck out of the jail
that everybody put you in.
- This is the past
audience I got (chuckles).
- And guess what?
They love you, and you love them.
- [Redman] That's right.
- But guess what?
I got shit on for not
being the wine guy anymore,
when I started talking about business
until I didn't.
I'm glad you came through, man.
- Appreciate you, boss.
- Did you understand?
- Yes.
- You gonna do something, you think?
- Absolutely. Why wouldn't I?
- I don't know, because it's fucking hard
to change up here sometimes.
- [Man] Alright, let me just.
- I think with the current
state of attention in podcasts.
This is a question to
you as well, equally.
What excites the shit out of me with this
is that it's super
narrow, and what scares me
about the next one is that it's too broad.
And I think to win on
podcast in the current state,
it'd probably be very smart for us
to go as narrow as possible.
(upbeat music)
- [Man] Okay, cool. Let's do this.
- Cool.
(upbeat music)
Nay.
What? (laughs)
What up, vlog?
Good day, just had a
brief PureWow meeting.
Everybody's subscribed to PureWow.
Iris is killing it, Sid not as much.
Marcus, definitely not.
- Real quick, three sentences
on New Year's resolution 2018.
- To do better than I did last year.
- That's it?
(upbeat music)
Daily resolutions, motherfuckers?
- [Woman] If you don't
know how to honor yourself,
ask the five people
who are closest to you.
- [Gary] That's it.
That's a great fucking question.
(upbeat music)
(honking)
Meaning I don't understand the question.
- [Woman] Uh, yeah. So one thing --
(upbeat music)
- [Man] The other
interesting thing about --
- [Man] The other interesting thing
that we're trying to do, just started it.
You either have to have --
- Alright, vlog, I'm out.
- [Man] Just thinking about it
(upbeat music)